that is almost a rapid unless you got  something that you want to do hit before  we before we leave cause you want me go  in the crowd because the crowd want you  to go to go in the crowd but you can't  sir I'm pretty good if Jack Christ is  proud sir  the diesel hey man you gonna hurt  somebody man be careful y'all he's not  he's not gonna serve he's just gonna go  in he might have to do that what's that  what's that big Mia when their body and  they did slam bodies with my booster it  might be body slamming it might be body  slam  I wouldn't do that I just want to go  without insurance policies are are just  giving high fives hi father we think  high five  no you know he's got something planned  we don't have that much money to pay off  all those losses if they have follow  people yes  yes oh he's gonna get the cow barks  barks see y'all fried in front of Main  streets we will